depuis 12 ans elle sillonne les rues du
tampon au volant de son camillon ben
Chantal Grondin exerce ce métier peu
commun pour une femme avec une passion
et un enthousiasme qui sont de
véritables boucliers au tensions et
dénigrements qui peuvent souvent se
venir au détour d'une poubelle ou d'un
feu vert et au tau comme partout dans le
monde c'est indispensable tâche à notre
bien-être n'est paradoxalement pas
toujours bien
perçu finalement le le la collègue des
ord ménageurs c'est un service qu'on rjo
c'est c'est c'est c'est un boulot
d'accord mais c'est surtout un service
qu'on range on les débarrasse de leur de
leur saleté parce que l'imession vousvez
oui c'est surtout à cause de ça bon je
trouve que c'est un travail vraiment
utile quoi bien sûr
voilà disons que mono si vous voulez on
fait notre boulot et quand c'est fini
ben voilà
on on a pas vraiment d'Ur
finalement ça dépend
de de la quantité qu'il y a quoi parce
que il y a des gens il y en a beaucoup
moins comme le mercredi il y en a il y
en a beaucoup moins donc on finit
beaucoup plus
tôt la vie
avec quels sont les véritables les
véritables inconvénients ce métier les
inconvénients c'est que les gens ils
sont pas très coopérents non ils sont
pas très coopérant du tout il pense
qu'on est obligé de faire ça que ben
finalement comme souvent ils nous ont
qualifié de
d'esclav qu' qu'on était leur leurs
leurs esclaves quoi finalement parce que
moi je sais pas ce qu'ils veulent dire
par là exactement il y a il y a dire et
dire quoi mais bon pour eux on est
obligé de faire ça et alors ils peuvent
se permettre de mettre n'importe quoi et
de de nous dire n'importe quoi et puis
ben voilà
et c'est ça c'est ça surtout et puis bon
et ben c'est souvent des insultes et
tout et puis il mettent des cadavres
d'animaux dedans ça j'ai j'ai jamais
compris il y a une décharge il a il y a
il y a une fourrière il y a tout ça pour
qu'il puisse je sais pas appeler ou
faire autre chose ou enterrer leur leurs
animaux morts et mais ils le font pas
alors bon ben ça c'est vraiment ça reste
des fois un ou de jours sur la route et
quand nous on les prend ben c'est pas
agréable c'est vraiment pas agréable
finalement si les gens il réfléchissent
il il pourraient nous remercier au moins
un petit peu de temps en temps quoi au
lieu de nous insulter à chaque fois au
moins une petit problème au moins une
petit truc mais dit-nous merci au moins
c'est on leur demande pas
grand-chose vous vous rappelez quand
vous avez été faire la la demande pour
avoir ce poste comment on vous a reçu et
quelles ont été le réactions j'ai été
reçu par le maire ben il était étonné il
m'a dit bah c'est sûr vous voulez faire
ça je dit bah oui il dit B vous avez
votre permis au moins je dis bah sinon
je serais pas venu je sais bien qu'il
faut le permis et puis il m'a dit ben je
vais appeler au chef mécanicien c'est là
qu'il l'a appelé et puis j'ai dit bah
écoutez là je sais que vous pourrez pas
me dire si c'est OK ou pas ok mais
j'attends une semaine plus plus le plus
que je vais attendre c'est 15 jours dans
15 jours si j'ai pas une réponse je
reviens mais c'est ce que j'ai fait au
bout de 15 jours je suis allé le revoir
et puis il m'a dit non t'inquiète pas là
il t'inquiète pas il y aura ton boulot
et puis une semaine après ben j'aiété
appelé pour pour commencer quoi sur sur
une période de 3 mois une durée de 3
mois et au fur et à mesure ça c'est ma
chain ce n'est pas un métier qui empêche
d'être féminine non pas du tout non et
vous n'avez pas une tenue de travail
spécial je veux dire c'est pas une
obligation c'est pas une obligation non
non on a on a une tenue on nous donne
une tenue mais moi je ça me dit rien la
ten non moi parce que je suis très
shortte et c'est des pantalons des des
combinaisons et ça me plaît pas du tout
c'esttout en période de chaleur c'est et
et bon ben j'aurais aimé que qu'on ait
des tenues plus plus souples aussi parce
que bon à la limite il pourrait nous
donner des t-shirts moi je préférre des
t-shirts ou chemis mise parce que veste
grande veste pantalon c'est pas terrible
est-ce que c'est un travail bien
rémunéré ma foi ça je peux disons je
gagne ma vie quoi sans plus oui voilà et
vous le faites parce que vous aimez
votre métier j'aime j'aime beaucoup mon
métier oui j'adore j'aime les camions
j'aime j'aime conduire vous aimez le
camion oui je trouve beau un camion
c'est vrai oui j'aime ça c'est c'est
génial c'est géant c'est grand c'est
fort c'est tout ce que vous voulez quoi
ouais
voilà normalement vous êtes assez
respecté en tant que femme avec vos vos
collègues hommes oui ça passe au début
ça parit pas trop il m'accepit pas
vraiment parce que bon mat show mat ch
hein mais au fil du temps quand ils ont
vu que ben je me laissis pas faire oui
ils se sont habitués quoi et que vous
faites bien votre travail oui finalement
je lu a dit que je les mettais au défi
et puis ça s'arrête
là tout dans
laaix est-ce qu'il a desbou femme non il
y en a pas c'est trop dur et je pense
qu'aucune femme ne
pourrait arriver à faire so très forte
physiquement non même pas ment non mais
c'est très dur moi je félicite les les
manœuvres qu'on a parce queil faut avoir
du cran pour faire ça faut avoir du cour
vraiment parce que sous le soleil sous
la pluie sous le vent quel que soit le
temps il faut bosser et puis c'est quand
même entre à 10 tonnes d'ordure par jour
à se partager en deux
donc très très physique et si on tient
pas le coup c'est si on est pas fort
c'est pas la
peine donc je vois des fois il rest
intéressé parce que je crois qu'ils on
fini oui je les vois courir
derrière vous avez des enfants oui j'en
ai deux un grand et un petit est-ce que
vous avez la possibilité vous avez le
temps de vous occuperux est-ce que ce
travail pas trop prenant non pas du tout
alors là c'est le travail que jusqu'à
maintenant j'ai trouvé le plus cool
ouais parce que ça me laisse du temps
libre d'accord ça c'est important ouais
c'est très très important donc ça me
gêne pas donc c'est plutôt agréable quoi
pour pour le petit surtout le grand
maintenant il s'en fiche mais bon ben
c'est bon quoi j'ai le temps pour les
deux de toute façon comment tu trouves
maman au volant du camion toi bien tu
aimes ça il il m'est arrivé de l'emmener
avec moi je demande l'utorisation tion
et puis bon et puis il aime ça hein il
adore ça quoi il voit bien partout bien
partout il il arrive qu'il s'endor mais
bon oui parce que vous avez des loisirs
ben oui je fais je fais quand même un
peu de vélo de temps en temps avec lui
un petit peu aussi il a son vélo pas
terrible enfin il arrive à monter dessus
bah sinon on fait des petites randonnées
quelque fois et puis on va à la mer et
tout ça quoi on sort de temps en temps
en famille et puis ben voilà une vie
bien rempli oui ah oui pour être rempli
c'est rempli hein et puis j'aime bien
sortir j'aime bien aller en
boîte j'aime bien danser j'aime bien
m'amuser avec mes amis mes copines quoi
il nous arrive de temps en temps de
sortir et puis de faire une bonne petite
soirée est-ce que le maire de votre
commune l' de vous oui je pense oui oui
oui il vous l' fait savoir oui parce que
quand on va des repas qu'il organise
c'est rare que j'y vais mais bon il
m'est arrivé d'y aller et ben ben il
arrête pas de de de lancer des éloges
quoi si je puis dire ça comme ça et puis
il fait un petit discours et h il
m'aperçoit il m'appelle et puis fait
fait savoir à tout le monde que je suis
là et puis c'est agréable ouais c'est
sympaa il est très content je pense
ouais
voilà all non remonte moi all sinon là
ça vous arrive d'être découragé ah oui
surtout quand le camion il sans prévenir
il nous il nous lâche en chemin oh là là
là ça j'aime pas du tout mais bon
j'arrive à le prendre quand même assez
bien quoi il y a des jours où si on se
réveille déjà pas bien on va bosser et
puis Pau sans nous prévenir il nous lu
ah ben alors là là
ça non non c'est c'est vraiment galère
là est-ce que vous échangeriez votre
camillon de benur contre un notre
camignon flambon neuf euh avec à
d'autres usages bien sûr ou alors un
grand bus euh contre un bus non
peut-être contre un beau camion oui oui
un beau camion hein par exemple un
benardordum mais plus plus moderne un
autre benardordium est très très moderne
c'est ce que vous souhaitez ah oui parce
que celui qu'on a en ce moment et ben
c'est pas trop terrible c'est un peu
vieux il faut changer donc si on me
donnerait un un beau camion wou ça
serait ça serait super avec radio et
tout à l'intérieur hein hein ça va de so
hein parce que sans radio bon c'est bien
monotone tout seul devantouiou c'est oui
voilà mais qu'est-ce que vous avez envie
de dire aux gens moi j'ai envie de dire
aux gens qu'il faudrait qu'ils
apprennent à être un petit peu plus
tolérant à être plus compétent à s'aimer
apprendre à s'aimer parce que
franchement il y a trop de violence trop
trop de ha trop de jalousie sur cette
terre et ça ça ça me dégoûte ça ça me
tue je suis quand je vois tout ça je ça
me rend malade franchement moi je leur
demande d'être un petit peu plus souple
voilà parce que apprendre à à savoir se
maîtriser un petit peu à être plus plus
cool quoi et allz à la
décharge oui parce qu'il fallait
l'autorisation pour
rentrer surtout qu'il voient une Ben
laordure et hop il commence à s fouler
ou bien il s'énerve il ins et tout ça là
et bon ben c'est pas agréable pour nous
je sais que c'est pas agréable pour eux
mais qu'il soit un petit peu plus
compréhensif nous nous on veut bien les
aider mais aide-nous aussi il faut qu'il
nous aide parce que s'il y a pas il y a
pas des deux côtés ça sert à quoi c'est
la c'est la guerre si on se met eux ils
se mettent à gueuler nous on répond
c'est la guerre donc ça nous a ça moi
personnellement ça m'a appris à être un
petit peu plus tolérante aussi dans dans
dans ma façon de voir les choses et puis
avoir quand même une certaine maîtrise
de ça vraiment une grande maîtrise de
soir parce que sinon c'est galère sinon
c'est foutu la vie elle est foutue aussi
sinon bon voilà c'est
fini on rentre chez
nous